hey guys it's dez de pana fake hero and
i'm david griffin your resident comic
book and video game guru and this is our
review of agents of shield episode 20
nothing personal Colbie Smulders showing
up yes I actually like her I heard that
she wanted to be more involved with the
show you know we know her she's Maria
Hill she was in Avengers the first time
we saw was in Avengers she pops up in
Captain America 2 and now you know and
she was in the premiere episode but we I
haven't seen her since then since the
premiere episode of agents of shield now
she's back I like her I liked her in how
i met your mother and she's a good
addition and you know this shows that
it's not a great show but it's slowly
improving and so it's it's one of those
shows where I don't run out and tell
people I call you gotta see agents of
shield but I feel like it's it's less of
a chore now watch it right and i'm semi
interested in what's going on and so in
that regard i like that that may came
back and I should beat up in there
getting yeah I like that I like that
scene i like i like that we're getting
like the whole you know marvel universe
is being included we get more than even
maybe last week's episode i felt i liked
it i like that you know she went see
spoilers if you haven't seen the captain
america movie i guess so but you should
have had by now uh at the end we know
that she starts working for a Tony Stark
yeah and Stark Industries so it's great
to see her mention that and be like look
that's only place I could get a job and
all that and I like that you know may or
no she also talked told Coulson like
Coulson you could go work for start
getting times I guess not my style and
that and I really like may like when she
went in there like knocked out all the
people that were watching her and they
had that conversation that was a nice
moment I do like Colbie Smulders yeah
and also it's one of those things we had
talked about this in the previous review
where now these references to the movie
universe aren't hollow and empty like
they were no rights easily yeah the
meanest season was like oh I've been
hanging out with Thor bubble I was like
just like these references that have no
meaning but these actually have
consequences and they're there they're
directly influencing each other you know
you have what happened in Captain
America too yeah and so now Maria Hill
is a stark and and and how that weighs
in with her relationship with Coulson
cuz to her she's like I've moved on this
is my new thing and agent Coulson's like
no no we gotta keep on with shield
they're going to revive it in
and make sure the good name of shield
doesn't get you know sullied right I
like that you know she said that you
know shield his dad like there is no
more she like you're saying I like that
like you know there is number more
Furies there but not the same capacity
is and maybe we won't know what shield
is really up to again if we get a second
season or we won't see encourage the
galaxy so maybe not until Avengers to me
probably we won't know age of Ultron we
don't know what exactly happened to
shield but yeah I like this episode I
think for me I like those parts and
Cobie Smulders you know agent may know
Ming on way was great but the whole
thing again with sky award and war it's
just I don't I mean this guy like trying
to play him and set him up I just don't
I don't care about them I still don't
care about them but I did like
everything else with Cobie Smulders and
all that I did like that I'm surprised
that they you know how we we talked
about how how quickly she found out
about about Ward and now I'm surprised
again at how quickly she revealed that
she knew and said Lord right so they
obviously did not want it I thought this
was gonna play out over maybe even neck
to neck season right but they they kind
of did that really quickly like BAM you
know I you know I like the scene in the
diner with the two of them because she
was obviously angry I have to you know
you know I've been critical of of the
character of sky and even the
performance I would say this was
probably her best episode ok I think in
terms of range of acting like there was
some of that emotion some anger some
frustration some so there was there was
more to the character in this episode
than I've seen in previous ones yeah
yeah I mean everybody even you know war
who still kind of flat like I think even
he's been able to do more now being the
double-a i liked it i did he still kind
of stay in bad i guess you know he has
it like you're not her both word like
you know he's like oh I'm conflicted
which he he would be somewhat conflicted
but I don't want to see him go good
again I just kinda want to see at least
stay bad for a long time for a while
like if it goes to next season having be
bad for next season two I like that but
I guess I mean the big reveal at the end
with may showing Coulson the video that
he is behind or was she say was behind
Tahiti supposedly if that's
who knows i thinkin manipulated space or
something I don't know but that was him
behind te telling agent fury we should
shut all this down yeah which he doesn't
remember no I so basically he was the
director of this special project that he
ended up being the test subject right
for and see how that plays out in
whatever secrets there he knows and you
know we've we've seen that it's it's
alien blood we said it was probably the
Kree Kree right now and see how that
plays and maybe that plays into the
Cinematic Universe as well maybe they're
gonna talk about that Avengers 2 who
knows right right so so that part was
cool no I liked it you know i mean it
sets the stage I mean we're getting
towards the finale think maybe two more
episodes left so you know we'll see what
happens i guess how they how they're
going to end this and where they're
going to leave this i mean it is better
than it was don't you know you keeps in
that every week but its true like I do
enjoys episodes more I'm so not really
into the show but it is better at least
in it was at least it's connected now
there's got some sesam have to it's go
yeah it definitely and that's the thing
there's more weight to this story now I
feel more danger for the characters
people have died people feel like
there's like in the beginning of season
it was just like haha you know whatever
now it feels like oh my god there's
people can die don't get hurt people get
betray of people's feet you know New
England I went care of May and an Olsen
are kind of on the outs but then there's
now kind of gonna reconnect and and all
that stuff it's just a much better one
thing though I have to complain about
played about before I just def Hawks
costume man it just no cheesy yeah and I
know like they don't have these big
budgets for like movies but still still
right terrible costume it was I saying
peterson again I mean yeah he's you know
kind of tuned in line between good and
bad he like he remembers his son which
he says like hey I left him in your care
like watch out for a mom going crazy
like I I do like him i was sure got to
see more of him a different capacity
hopefully we'll see more of him as a
show show goes on but you know we're
almost there i'm gonna season yeah
there's a two more episodes the next
episode looks like it's gonna I actually
am very interested in this one cuz this
is the back history of Garrett an award
yeah and how Ward became so loyal to
Gary
has been great exactly and so I think
this next episode I'm going to quite
enjoy and we're gonna see some history
all right so that's what we thought of
this episode of agents of shield you can
post comments below on the website think
hero.com or on our youtube channel think
hero pro make sure to subscribe to that
you'll also find us on twitter we're at
think hero i'm at griffin de and we have
a Facebook page that's facebook.com
slash think hero fans make sure you like
that page and you can share our video on
Twitter Facebook and all that stuff
you